[Music]
on this tuesday night twas the fight
before christmas
booming demand for boosters and covet 19
tests as omicron overwhelms it's so
contagious that everyone's going to be
exposed in a matter of weeks breaking
news from bc as the province beefs up
its pandemic protocols
holiday travel trouble the new rules and
advice for visitors in some provinces
this variant does not care if we are
weary from omicron testing times to
treatment options doctors answer more of
your covid19 questions
and oh christmas tree the holiday staple
suddenly in short supply we're going to
see the effects of this for years to
come we'll get to the root of the
problem
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin again tonight with the rapid
rise in covet 19 cases and restrictions
in canada driven by that highly
transmissible variant omicron and it was
another record-breaking day take a look
here are the numbers so far with record
case counts reported in bc nova scotia
and quebec which topped 5 000 new cases
for the first time omicron is now the
dominant strain in ontario which
reported more than 3 400 cases with a
test positivity rate of almost 10
percent but the key metric we're
watching of course is hospitalizations
ontario's chief medical officer of
health said that of the 4 600 ontarians
with confirmed cases of omicron a
relatively small number just 15 have
been hospitalized
even if it's much less virulent its
attack rate could mean that it spreads
so rapidly
that it it will have a an effect on our
hospital sector and this is what he's
worried about take a look the fast
climbing case numbers a steeper curve
than anything we've seen so far in this
pandemic which risks overwhelming our
hospitals once again
health officials say our best weapon
against omicron is a vaccine booster
shot but already the demand for those
boosters and for covid19 tests are
overwhelming our health systems mike
cherlay has our top story tonight
this rec center wasn't just the hot spot
for handing out rapid antigen tests on a
frigid ottawa warning it was the only
spot
the line started at 4 am the bad news
came at 7. right now they're delayed
from toronto with no tests to offer
workers apologized handed out ious and
took their lumps this is terrible
absolutely terrible
this this isn't acceptable i'm not
blaming you
thank you for not blaming us and it's
not their fault the speed with which
omicron has spread has overwhelmed the
system two weeks ago vaccination clinics
were nearly empty
today mississauga residents lined up
over five hours for the chance to get
one of 300 booster shots from a pop-up
clinic and while there were no testing
kits available in ottawa here they were
handed out to those waiting in line just
a little bonus i guess peace of mind
perhaps but not the definitive or most
accurate covet test daniel baer started
to feel ill last wednesday i just i let
my guard down a little bit one time and
i think that was
probably all it took he twice tested
negative before finally confirming he
had coveted with three successive
antigen tests on the weekend for public
health to consider him coveted positive
he needs a pcr test but the earliest
spot he could book was the end of the
week i don't need a pcr test for
vanity's sake i need a pcr test so that
the school can notify other families
that i was there for pick up dr rawat
dianandin says we better get used to
supply issues and delays because ontario
for one has said it may have to start
rationing pcr tests to keep up with
omicron i mean it's crazy contagious
i've been saying that delta is the most
contagious respiratory virus we've ever
seen in modern times omicron leaves
delta in the dust
it's so contagious that everyone's going
to be exposed in a matter of weeks
everybody
so you can't test everybody in a matter
of weeks and that could make the holiday
season a little less merry for everyone
microlight global news toronto
to some breaking news out of bc now
where its daily covid caseload just hit
a record-breaking 1308
a significant jump just from yesterday
tonight that province is unveiling tough
new restrictions to try to slow the
spread of omicron
we know
that this is a
disappointing and discouraging thing to
hear at this point in time people in bc
have stepped up we've done the right
thing over and over but
the challenge that we have is this virus
doesn't recognize that
what it does it has changed and so must
we
global bc's legislative bureau chief
keith baldry joins us now so keith walk
us through the main changes here
yeah the changes i mean we're really
going backwards we've seen these changes
before different parts of the pandemic
and it also comes on a day when we're
setting a near record of 1308 uh coven
19 cases so
closure of bars and clubs that don't
have a food license we're going to see
also a ban on gatherings in terms of
weddings funerals and receptions also
going to see gyms fitness centers and
dance studios close the goal is to
minimize the social gatherings of people
in close quarters particularly in indoor
settings the rule that was announced on
friday will remain in place a maximum of
10 people added to your household for
any social indoor gathering and finally
again six people at a table is the
maximum for restaurants the restaurants
really dodged a bullet here they were
fearing they were going to see crowd
capacity limits such as we're seeing in
ontario and quebec that didn't happen
today so the restaurant's got a bit of a
break today
interesting and keith uh we also heard
the bc is ramping up the use of rapid
tests what should we expect there
nothing in the short term lots of them
in january the government's been feeling
the heat about a lack of rapid testing
out there but they are going to purchase
almost 12 million rapid tests in january
use them in various ways but the
strategy it doesn't seem to change it's
not going to be a lot of take-home tests
it's going to be targeted testing where
they think it's most required in
indigenous communities in health
compromised communities and in places
really where you need them
keith baldry in victoria bc tonight
thanks keith and alberta is also
bringing in some new restrictions as it
deals with its own spike in cases
starting december 24th venues with a
capacity of more than 1 000 people will
be capped at 50 capacity no food or
drinks will be allowed at large events
and restaurants will be limited to 10
people per table
the alberta government is also offering
booster shots to all adults 18 and up
effective immediately as long as it's
been more than five months since your
last shot
tightening restrictions and surging
cases are also further complicating
canadians holiday travel plans even for
those who are planning to travel within
the country jamie morocco reports on the
inter-provincial travel rules
[Music]
omicron is quickly becoming the variant
that stole christmas
it does not care if the holiday season
is upon us
it does not care if we have travel plans
or if our loved ones from away want to
come home for the holidays
starting wednesday visitors to prince
edward island will be met with a
mandatory four-day quarantine in
newfoundland and labrador self-isolation
is being enforced for five days it is
really in every province at the moment
and i don't think that inter-provincial
travel bans at the moment are really
likely to accomplish anything
incredibly useful even health canada
isn't discouraging moving around
inter-provincially yet instead the focus
has been on international travel
i will say it again
now is not the time to travel
a stern warning to avoid leaving the
country citing possible changes to
travel rules and complications of
contracting covet abroad
janet waikitz isn't canceling her trip
to florida on boxing day but testing
requirements she says aren't making it
easy
we've called probably 15 to 20
pharmacies
and while we were able to book at one
they called back and canceled because
they said they're all on short staff for
christmas day appointments in ontario
are becoming harder and harder to get on
short notice as omicron cases surge and
when it comes to testing for
non-essential reasons like a trip health
canada says people are on their own
wicket says she'll be missing christmas
driving two hours to a costly private
clinic to get hers i mean our kids are
adults it doesn't make it
any less
guilt-inducing i'm going to have to
abandon them a decision she says she's
been forced to make just to get away
this holiday season jamie morocco global
news toronto
in the u.s the omicron variant is now
the dominant strain of covid19 and cases
there are also climbing fast new
infections are pushing the country's
curve to its highest level since the
summer more than 143 000 cases are now
being reported on average every day
that's up 20 percent from just two weeks
ago the first death from omicron in the
u.s has also now been recorded a texas
man who was unvaccinated and today
president joe biden announced new
measures to take on the new variant
jackson proskow has the view from
washington
just days before christmas long lines
for covid testing are everywhere if i'm
positive i will not be going to see
family the rapid surge in positive cases
is unprecedented in the u.s and there
are unusually dire warnings about the
ability for hospitals to cope even if
only a small proportion are severe
especially in places that don't have
vaccination coverage we are going to be
faced with crushing demands on the
health care system good afternoon
against that backdrop president joe
biden announced a plan to combat the
omicron variant we should all be
concerned about omicron
but not panicked
biden plans to distribute half a billion
at-home tests federal agencies will be
tapped to run booster clinics and
support hospitals there was no
announcement of new federal restrictions
or mandates i know some americans are
wondering
if you can safely celebrate the holidays
with your family and friends
the answer is yes you can
if you and those you celebrate with are
vaccinated
yet as biden encouraged americans to
proceed with their holiday plans he also
acknowledged the possibility of
widespread but mild breakthrough
infections will be positive cases in
every office even here in the white
house it's all a stark contrast from the
message just five months ago today
we are closer than ever
to declaring our independence from a
deadly virus instead the u.s has
remained gripped by the pandemic we will
not comply divided over masks and
vaccine mandates as tens of thousands
have needlessly died
and millions more remain unwilling to
get vaccinated there is some potential
good news for anyone who might become
severely ill during this latest surge
bloomberg reports that two new antiviral
treatments designed specifically for
covid19 could be approved as early as
this week in studies they've shown to be
up to 90 percent effective at reducing
death and hospitalization
jeff jackson prosco in washington thanks
jackson
a new year brings new restrictions in
europe coming up the upcoming rules for
anyone who wants to travel freely in the
eu
plus staggering divorce settlement the
hefty sum dubai's ruler is being forced
to fork out
new zealand is delaying its border
reopening plans due to the spread of
omicron quarantine free travel for
australians will be pushed back from
mid-january to the end of february
foreign tourists won't be allowed into
new zealand until april new zealand has
reported 22 cases of omicron all of
those coming in travelers arriving from
abroad
the european union has also announced
new travel rules that will make covet
booster shots mandatory to travel freely
within the eu without testing or
quarantine the european commission says
the block's digital covid certificate
will only be valid for nine months after
a person's second dose after that a
booster shot is needed to renew the
certificate the new measure still needs
to be approved by all eu members but
it's expected to come into effect in
february
a british court has ordered the ruler of
dubai to pay his ex-wife and their
children more than 900 million dollars
it's one of the most expensive divorce
settlements in british history sheikh
muhammad bin rasheed al-maktoum was
ordered to pay nearly half of the
settlement to his sixth wife and the
rest to their two daughters the trio
fled to the uk in 2019 the princess
sought custody of their two kids through
british courts saying she was terrified
of her husband
can the highly contagious variant open a
path to herd immunity we're answering
your omicron questions next
anyone looking to make a quick
cross-border christmas shopping trip
will now require a negative covid19 test
before returning home starting today the
federal government is requiring anyone
entering the country to show proof of a
negative pcr test the health minister
announced the new rules on friday citing
the surge in omicron infections before
now travelers re-entering the country
after short trips of less than 72 hours
were not required to take a test
well from testing to treatment we have
received a lot of questions from viewers
about the omicron variant and to answer
some of those now we are joined by
infectious disease expert dr dan gregson
and epidemiologist dr christopher labos
thank you gentlemen both for joining us
so
dr labos first to you to you and we have
a question here from kevin who says that
he's been in contact with a person who
has confirmed positive for omicron how
long before he might also test positive
so you probably won't test positive
during the first few days of the uh
after the exposure so day one and day
two you probably won't but by day three
four and five uh if you are infected you
probably will test positive at that
point and then if you know if you get
too far away from the initial exposure
after about day seven or eight the
likelihood of you testing positive
starts to drop off again okay very good
to know next question comes from joe
with a question about masks and so dr
gregson this one to you uh joe sees
people wearing face shields with no face
masks all the time wondering how
effective these face shields and face
masks are against the omicron variant
short answers they're not um
this is a bit of misinformation that
that face shields are used to prevent
transmission of respiratory infections
that's not what happens we use face
shields in addition to masks
to reduce the risk of transmission so
they're an added feature they're not a
single feature so to speak
okay uh next question comes from lori
this one for you dr labos asking if
there are any treatment options against
omicron and asking specifically about
antibody treatments that are widely
available in the united states
yeah so i think this is a common
misconception there are actually
multiple treatments for covid and
there's no reason to think that the
treatments for omicron would be
different than they would for all the
other variants of covid i mean at its
very basics it's uh steroids which were
one of the first treatments to be used
there are some antivirals
from the severe being one there are the
new oral pills that were developed by
merkin by pfizer but those aren't really
used yet
and there are a number of other
treatments as well the concern has
always been that antibody based
treatments might not be as effective
because of the differences between
omicron and the original strains but all
this to say in brief there are actually
multiple treatments for covid
that can help speed the recovery of
people when they're in hospital but of
course always much better to not get
covet in the first place and that's the
benefit of vaccines you actually prevent
disease rather than treating you after
you get sick
right excellent point of course and back
over to you dr gregson next question
comes from rod this is a common question
actually we've received a lot of asking
about herd immunity so if omicron is
highly contagious and a large percentage
of the population of canada were to
catch it and then recover
would we be able to go back to normal
so
respiratory viruses aren't like some
other viruses we see circulating in the
environment so
um
what generally happens is we have a wave
of virus come through we develop
immunity
the virus then mutates a little bit we
have another wave of virus come through
and we develop immunity
our current problem is we don't large
partisan postulation doesn't have
immunities bringing these big waves
uh and that as we more and more develop
immunity to just different variants
we'll have fewer and fewer
waves and they'll be
not as big as time goes by
okay last question to you dr labos we're
almost out of time but this one from
jaclyn who notes uh with omicron
spreading so rapidly throughout the
world what are your thoughts on the odds
of the virus going through another even
more concerning mutation
well it's certainly possible especially
if we don't control covet globally if we
allow covet to spread and to be
spreading rapidly in various parts of
the world in various countries where
vaccine uptake is low then yes this
could happen again this is how delta
emerged this is how omicron emerged so
unless we know once this wave is over if
we don't realize and remember that we
need to get vaccines to countries where
uh supply of vaccination is low this
probably will keep happening so we have
to remember that we have to control
this virus not just in canada but
control it globally
ugh thanks for nothing on that last one
uh doctors dan gregson christopher lavos
gentlemen really appreciate your time
thanks for tackling these questions for
us
you're welcome have a great day
and we will be putting questions about
omicron straight to the experts all week
so please send us yours to your
questions at globalnews.ca
christmas tree troubles next why
california's climate has uprooted the
supply
welcome back it's hard to imagine the
holidays without one the christmas tree
is a centerpiece for many family
gatherings and it's especially festive
if you find a real one but on the u.s
west coast christmas trees are harder to
come by this year rob malcolm explains
dazzler farms has long been a staple of
the fall season in california growing
pumpkins and this year they are also in
the christmas tree business but with
wildfires and unprecedented drought that
transition hasn't been easy
many west coast sellers who rely on
supply from california and oregon have
had a hard time filling their lots they
don't have the tree supply like they
used to between the fires and the
drought the supply just isn't there
wildfires in 2020 had already wiped out
several christmas tree farms in
california and with unprecedented
drought in 2021 even more farms have
struggled meaning fewer trees overall
and that's a driven price is up
christmas trees are fun way up i mean i
have a lot of clients that are on the
real estate agent like they complain all
the time about the prices this year it's
getting crazy this year alone the cost
of real trees is estimated to be up 20
percent over last year and that's on top
of the increases already felt over the
past few years
while the biggest might be on the price
there's also been an impact on the size
of the trees between fires and drought
combined like this year it was almost
impossible to get tall trees and then a
few years skyrocketing tree prices and
height won't be the only issue that's
because it takes 6 to 10 years to grow a
christmas tree to maturity and when
seedlings have been damaged because of
drought and wildfires the impacts will
be felt for years to come it's not a
dying business but christmas tree farms
like bobby dazzlers just outside of
sacramento understand what's at stake
and they say christmases in the future
could look a little bit differently
we're going to see the effects of this
for years to come for some consumers
switching christmas traditions to
include an artificial tree might be the
answer in the long term but amid supply
chain issues artificial trees have been
in short supply this year too supply and
demand it's on everything so this
christmas real trees may look a little
different and cost more but with
droughts and wildfires becoming more
prevalent in a state already suffering
there are questions about whether
christmas trees will become harder and
harder to come by in the coming years
forcing a switch to artificial for many
consumers rob malcolm global news
sacramento
sorry santa that is global national for
this tuesday night i'm jeff semple today
is the winter solstice an important
event for many cultures including
canada's indigenous peoples so we leave
you tonight with these sculptures in
edmonton by cree artist jason carter
marking the longest night of the year
they represent the grandfather's son the
grandmother moon and mother earth each
holding a light to care for us in the
darkness thanks for watching hope to see
you back here again tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you